you like cracker ass well I'd like to
insult you back but I can't say it
because it would be a hate crime let it
be said that I think uh very rude but
the recent news of Virginia Governor
Norris from having soiled the bed given
the recent picture of him surfacing in
blackface and/or KKK by the way comment
below let me know what you think is more
offensive we decided to call as the open
minds we pulling you Center for small
businesses and black influencers to see
what they thought hi this is Stacy mayo
and I'm calling with open minds we pull
you Center for black business owners and
influencers and good news that you've
been identified as a key influencer in
your community we work with black
business managers and owners on a
grassroots level and if you could have
fine maybe two minutes of your time I
literally have four questions to ask for
you would really help us out and a
grassroots effort thank you very much hi
but I think what's the manager and/or
business owner there please is there a
shift manager there what do you want to
add okay good so it's actually about the
current governor of Virginia and this
says as it relates to business owners
let me ask you three questions what
governor Norseman's proposed 1.2 billion
dollars in tax increases make you more
or less likely to support him less less
why that taxes are killing you okay so
no one tax I mean I think abortions I
think it should be the woman's decision
okay less okay so you're pro-life
okay great hello hi I just called here
for oh I just called one second I don't
need to speak with the manager or
business owner anyone who's just in
charge right now in the current shift
would that be yourself sir no that
wouldn't be me you got away Thursday
well know who you're working there who
right there is working today who I could
speak with for just three minutes so
we're trying to see what it would take
to regain the black vote and
specifically bat black business owners
let me ask you would it be more
offensive because we don't know what it
is yet if he had dressed in the
blackface or if he were in the KKK
uniform which would you say it's worth
just affecting put your picture up there
period are you like I'm okay oh I heard
not to answer if I see me they're all
engaged I think we're all one people one
people but sure either you white or your
black are you black yes okay I'm white I
am why you're white yes yes that so you
don't have to the dancer don't question
asked me well no I just want to know if
it's more offensive blackface okay great
okay I'll put it I'll put you down for a
KKK is more offensive than black
baseness final question would recently
surfaced photos of him dressed in
blackface and or as a member of the KKK
in his medical school yearbook make you
more or less likely to support him
really why because he far as him being
black faced and all that in a yearbook I
wouldn't want to support that well to be
fair it's his medical school yearbook so
it's not high school
he's substantially older it's after a
basic matter he was if he was ever
racist I wouldn't want the boy okay
hey let me ask you would it be more
offensive to you as I presume a woman of
color if he were in blackface or if it
were him in the KKK uniform which would
be worse as a black woman business owner
whoa the KKK that'd be worse than
blackface you think yeah what makes you
say that so I just want why would you
say the cake you can't switch this is
really important if you hang up and I
had a sneaking suspicion that I might
make some more headway using a different
phone tech hello ward hey man what's up
I'm calling because I'd actually like to
get catering done for my wedding okay
so who would I talk to about that
the wedding is actually gonna be in July
what's your name sir Otis yeah thank you
now it's gonna be a pretty big wedding
about 120 you know 180 people depending
on what the bride wants you know uh-huh
so is it that kind of so do you have
experience what's that what kind of a
spread would I've been looking at
full-service catering because we don't
we don't offer full-service catering we
do large orders but we don't we can't
you know we don't bring the food there
and serve it we don't have that okay no
that's I can have someone come pick it
up though but y'all can make food for
enough for that many people okay and do
you need to change like a manager like
the owner or something like that oh
really
uh-huh you're racist you're racist you
hung up on me two seconds ago you said
there was no business manager owner
there now I'm just trying to get pulled
up from you what are you doing what are
you doing that's not right that's not
right that's what Jesse Jackson was
talking about I cannot believe that you
would tell a white person there was no
manager or business owners there and I
called back he thought it was a black
guy and you're answering well I'd like
to insult you back but I can't say it
because it would be a hate crime let it
be said that I think you're very rude
okay so you're happy now are you happy
now you all need a subject that was
happen I don't want to suck you you gay
huh well I'm actually calling from open
minds we pull you Center for business
owners and managers and I just wanted to
ask you if you can give me three minutes
of your time for very important
questions regarding governor some
surprises here but we decided to go
straight to the top and call someone at
the n-double-a-cp Wow hello yeah I'm
sorry if I've reached the end of LACP
today
my name is Jamil mail I'm calling action
with open minds we pull you Center for
black business owners and influencers
and actually if I could grab two minutes
of your time that would help - I just
have about four very important questions
regarding the current business political
climate in Virginia and it could be
anybody who works with the n-double-a-cp
in any capacity um all right all right
does governor northerns position on
abortion that it should be freely
accessible up until and including the
third trimester does that make you more
or less likely or more likely to support
him okay more follow-up would his
support for post-birth abortion after
the baby has been safely delivered make
you more or less likely to support him
again I'm gonna say more more likely to
support post birth abortion okay
would right would recently surface
photos of him dressed in blackface
and/or as a member of the KKK in his
medical school yearbook make you more or
less likely to support him I just came
from speaking at a protest right told
him to resign the NAACP's official
positions that he should resign it
doesn't really have that much to do with
the photograph it has to do with his
current policies that are not supported
okay can I ask you just a couple
questions here so when has it become
officially like the n-double-a-cp
position to ask governor Northam to
resign when did
happy Saturday Saturday afternoon
Saturday oh cool it okay so it's about
Union Hill it just so happens well-well
coincide and the other right and the
other problems of the horse is the
governor basically apologized on Friday
and then on Saturday said oh gee gosh
golly That's not me
right I know I thought you'd caught you
bug blanket on the bathroom flow hey
wasn't me you just said with you nothing
right Andrew what you think which one
you think it was you think it was
blackface or you think it was a KKK I
think it was black face in that picture
you think it was black face what do you
think will be worse though like if it
was if he were in blackface or if he won
the KKK cuz that's my final question I
was gonna about to ask y'all but I know
you educated me on Union Hill I don't
even know happen to my own backyard
no no no I am in about it no more but do
you think that it was black you think it
was blackface but would it be more
offensive if it were blackface or if it
were KKK which do you think is worse
because I go back and forth here's why
the KKK is worse okay um
black isn't insult the KKK killed and
dismembered black people yeah that's
true but the black face is ugly you know
you get a get a ten a Kiwi shoe polish
and rub that all over like it seems it
seems like more in-your-face like an
insult like look I'm looking all black
in my face he thought about being in
blackface to quote imitate Michael
Jackson in a dance contest but that's
like white face right okay now now I am
going to assume that you went to college
why why would we do that because I'm
relatively articulate yeah okay well
thank you very much yes you are correct
all right all right no let me ask you
this
I know the n-double-a-cp support and
Northam right the election I have that
correct yeah yeah and when you're
looking like at brick having all what
happened like did he did he not do this
right and everyone's coming out there
and they know it like
you think ain't nobody surfaced this
before not like these pictures it's not
like it's junior high yearbook it's
medical school right on and older again
things get interesting
meaning the Democratic Party know and
they just ignored it because they're
pretty much as racist as he is but what
about journal I though like what about
CNN you know ABC why didn't they find it
I mean they can find stuff from you know
when they would tell Mike Cavanaugh gore
sick like the car clubs they were in
people you know 7-elevens they hung out
with they can't find a guy who's in
blackface and or KKK that remains to be
seen like ain't nobody furnish you know
I mean apparently not nope nope nope and
on either eight they weren't looking or
be they just gave him an automatic yeah
and because like you said Democrats have
racist says party you think they said
well he's a Democrat so he cool we're
gonna let him through even though he's
cool man MJ blackface shoe polish with
like he cool because he's a Democrat hey
Otis I'm sorry man I feel like we got
off on the wrong foot and I got a little
heated there
I'd like to apologize we are we are we
are we cool we're cool I just you know I
got it got heated you know I felt like
you were sliding me a little bit cuz I
was a white guy and I let my anger get
the better I'm working on it I just
wanted to make yeah I know but you know
Carm out there you don't want it to be
bad karma you know you don't want to go
around and in and I don't want to I
don't want to treat people that way and
I know you probably don't want to do we
don't want to respond an anger so I just
wanted to make sure that called and
cleared it up and I want to make sure
we're cool we don't have to be cool okay
man well we don't have to be cool but
hey if you could do me a small favor and
answer three questions I am calling from
a polling agency regarding the current
Virginia governor and we're just it
would really help my job right now just
answered literally yes or no questions I
got three to go through with you
okay I would appreciate it if you don't
call this number again so what is
support of mothers oh that's